[Música]
Hola soy Santiago López González
Bienvenidos a Kobe 19 la semana en
América el espacio de France 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia de Kobe 19 en nuestro
continente a continuación algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar en este
programa
siendo el mes de junio el mes del
orgullo gay o del Orgullo lgbtiq
analizaremos como la pandemia de Kobe 19
descuidó la batalla contra el VIH como
la vacunación contra el Kobe 19 puede
también afectar a las personas que
padecen el virus de inmunodeficiencia
humana Y cómo las vacunas del ARN
mensajero como la de pfizer o la de
moderna pueden ser un buen precedente
para desarrollar una vacuna contra el
VIH esperada por más de tres décadas
tendremos a un invitado para conversar
sobre este tema también hay noticias
positivas en América Latina Cuba
confirmó que la vacuna abdala
desarrollada localmente tiene una
eficacia superior al 92%. se trata de la
primera vacuna desarrollada en América
Latina y de recibir una certificación
puede ser una nueva Esperanza para
reforzar los planes de vacunación en
diferentes países alrededor del mundo
tenemos todos los detalles y también
esta semana hubo muchos anuncios y
noticias Como por ejemplo los
récords de víctimas mortales en Colombia
y en Brasil el inicio de la vacunación
de adolescentes en Chile también el
aumento de los casos en México después
del inicio de las clases presenciales y
también los casos reportados de la
variante Delta todo esto mientras en
Brasil avanza la Copa América y también
la región suramericana allí Está
avanzando la apertura económica seguimos
preguntándonos si era el momento para
una apertura económica tendremos
reportes de nuestros corresponsales
pues ya lo estamos diciendo estamos por
terminar el mes de junio el mes del
orgullo gay y queríamos hablar de una de
las problemáticas que más le preocupa a
esta comunidad y es el VIH como el
surgimiento de la pandemia del covid 19
dejó a esta enfermedad prácticamente en
un segundo plano pero la mortalidad y
también los números de casos siguen
latentes siguen en aumento para analizar
esta situación hemos invitado al doctor
José González Zamora él es especialista
en enfermedades infecciosas también es
investigador de la vacuna moderna en la
Universidad de Miami en de la Florida
además es investigador de plasma del
convaleciente del Jackson Memorial
Hospital doctor Gracias por estar con
nosotros Gracias por acompañarnos y
comienzo por preguntarle varios
organismos internacionales han alertado
o por lo menos han evidenciado que la
lucha contra el VIH ha quedado
prácticamente de lado en cierta forma
debido a la pandemia del Coby 19 ha
quedado relegada la batalla contra este
virus
Sí yo creo que la pandemia de de
coronavirus ha hecho que muchos de las
métodos diagnósticos de la estrategia de
diagnóstico y también de Educación
comunitaria haya quedado relegada
justamente para poder prioridad a esta
pandemia que ha cobrado muchas muertes
Lamentablemente esto ha hecho que los
sistemas de diagnóstico que el
diagnóstico de VIH haya disminuido de
forma significativa aquí en Estados
Unidos se reporta una disminución de
aproximadamente 50% de las pruebas
diagnósticas y también vemos que el
coronavirus ha impactado en la economía
y esto ha hecho que muchas personas
infectadas de VIH pierdan su seguro
médico lo cual hace que vayan a
confiarse en los recursos dados por los
mecanismos federales como Ryan White
aquí en localmente en Estados Unidos lo
cual hace que las medicinas no lleguen
en el tiempo correcto y puedan tal vez
en algún momento no continuar con su
tratamiento y Esto hace que se perpetúe
la pandemia o la epidemia en este caso
de VIH
doctor González las vacunas que están en
el mercado contra el Coby 19 ninguna de
ellas parte específicamente del virus
todas han tenido
una composición distinta hablan de de un
sistema de producción distinto que es el
ARN viajero o mensajero que es una
técnica completamente diferente por eso
inocular a personas con VIH resulta que
no es para nada peligroso Pero entonces
como han reaccionado las personas que
tienen VIH que ya han recibido una o dos
vacunas que estudios han hecho en este
grupo de la población que reacciones han
visto en este segmento de personas que
tienen este virus
sí hay que recordar que las vacunas de
coronavirus son completamente eficaces y
seguras en todas las poblaciones
incluida la población con VIH lo que se
ha visto en este último momento es que
estas personas no han desarrollado mayor
mayores efectos secundarios comparados
con la población general lo que sí
podríamos manifestar es que las personas
con VIH con un sistema inmunológico de
sumamente suprimido me refiero con un
cd4 menor de 200 están en riesgo de no
desarrollar una inmunidad correcta o una
inmunidad suficientemente potente contra
el coronavirus al administrarse las
vacunas es así que a estas personas se
les recomienda todavía continuar con
medidas de mitigación a pesar de de
haber recibido la vacuna contra el
coronavirus pero si tenemos que hablar
de seguridad estas vacunas han mostrado
seguridad absoluta en pacientes con VIH
me preguntaba uno de los televidentes a
través de las redes sociales una persona
que es diagnosticada con VIH va a
recibir alguna de las vacunas que está
disponible en el mercado dependiendo de
la composición de estas vacunas Cuál es
la que mejor efecto le puede surtir en
este paciente le pregunto porque por
ejemplo la vacuna desarrollada en China
la vacuna sinovac esta vacuna es muy
buena mitigando un poco los efectos que
puede tener el Coby 19 dado el caso que
la persona se contagia pero no es tan
eficaz a la hora de prevenir que el
virus entra al organismo mientras que
las vacunas Como por ejemplo la de
pfizer y la de moderna sí son mucho más
efectivas a la hora de alejar el virus
del organismo y por lo tanto pues la
persona tiene un alto porcentaje de no
llegar a contagiarse de Kobe 19 dadas
las condiciones que tiene un paciente
con VIH Cuál es la que más le conviene
yo creo que también depende mucho de la
disponibilidad de vacunas en ciertas
localidades o en ciertos países hay que
recordar que todas las vacunas al
momento ha mostrado una gran eficacia
sobre todo para prevenir enfermedades
severa Y también una seguridad muy alta
Así que si tenemos que hacer algunos
datos comparativos entre las vacunas de
virus inactivo Me refiero a las vacunas
comparativamente con las vacunas de
nueva tecnología con ARN mensajero o
adenovirus tendríamos que decir que
estas últimas proveen mucho más
beneficios sobre todo porque disminuye
la capacidad de contagiar disminuye la
infección asintomática y también corta
la transmisión comunitaria en un mundo
ideal Yo diría que las vacunas de
tecnología de tecnología más avanzada
como de ARN mensajero se muestran como
muy superiores y tendría que darse mayor
prioridad pero de esto depende muchísimo
de cada localidad y de la disponibilidad
de vacunas en cada país
precisamente le preguntó doctor González
por esas vacunas de pfizer y de modernos
te lo explicaba mejor esto es un avance
tecnológico por esta forma en la que fue
desarrollada por el ARN en mensajero es
una técnica completamente Revolucionaria
esto no sienta un buen precedente para
poder desarrollar una vacuna contra el
virus de inmunodeficiencia humana que
llevamos más de tres décadas
prácticamente esperando el desarrollo de
una vacuna que sea 100% efectiva
Sí definitivamente crea un buen
precedente y hay que recordar que
también se están haciendo algunos
estudios con esta tecnología de ARN
mensajero para poder luchar contra el
VIH pero también contra otras patologías
como el cáncer también hay que destacar
que una de las tecnologías nuevas
utilizadas por la vacunación
llámese de Johnson and Johnson o de
Oxford que utilizan vectores de
adenovirus actualmente se encuentra
también aplicada a la lucha contra el
VIH ya que tenemos un ensayo clínico
fase 3 denominado mosaico que está
llevado a cabo por chance que está
utilizando esta tecnología esperemos
tener resultados pronto sobre la
eficacia y poder tener una herramienta
más para luchar contra el VIH sería un
golpe de suerte para la humanidad doctor
González que fuera desarrollado una
vacuna contra el VIH y fuera
desarrollado una vacuna 100% efectiva
contra el Coby 19 la luz puede estar al
final del túnel muy pronto Muchas
gracias doctor González por estar con
nosotros aquí en 19 la semana en América
aquí en France 24 vamos a cambiar de
tema hablemos ahora de algunas de las
cifras las cifras de contagio y de
fallecidos en diferentes países de
nuestro continente para el cierre de
esta semana Así es como están las cosas
comenzamos en Argentina este país tiene
más de 4.3 millones de casos confirmados
y más de 91 mil personas han fallecido
Perú superó ya los dos millones de casos
mientras que los fallecidos son más de
91.400 Canadá en el extremo Norte del
continente tiene más de 1.4 millones de
casos y 26.100 personas ya han perdido
la vida allí en este país devolvámonos
Entonces hasta el Sur del continente
Paraguay Allí más de 413.000 personas
han sido confirmadas con Kobe 19
mientras que más de 12.000 han fallecido
por último Panamá este país contabiliza
397 mil casos y más de 6.500 personas
han fallecido
nos vamos ahora hasta México allí han
comenzado a registrar un pico de
contagio recientemente después de que
fue autorizada la vacunación para los
adolescentes mayores de 12 años
Únicamente con la vacuna desarrollada
por la farmacéutica pfizer Byron vamos a
ver entonces cómo está la situación en
este país conectamos en Ciudad de México
con Mario carbonell Mario como siempre
Un gusto saludarlo aquí en Kobe 19 la
semana en América y comenzó
preguntándole por ese repunte que está
presentando México después de que se
presentara una leve baja en las cifras
en las últimas semanas y este posible
pico puede ser mucho más agresivo parece
estar de vuelta esos esas semanas en
donde se veían los hospitales otra vez
saturados y las personas en
confinamiento en diferentes partes de la
República Mexicana
Así es Después de varias semanas de una
tendencia a la baja México vive un
repunte de casos de Kobe 19 por primera
vez esta semana se superó desde el mes
de abril la Barrera de los 5000
contagios confirmados para un solo día
para llegar a un total de dos y medio
millones de contagios desde el inicio de
la pandemia la Ciudad de México que ya
estaba en semáforo epidemiológico verde
tuvo que volver al amarillo Pues hay una
tendencia al alza Se pasó de un promedio
de 240 casos diarios a 631 entre el 24
de mayo y el 22 de junio es un aumento
que está pegando más a la población
joven de entre 20 y 39 años y que
también se refleja en el aumento de
hospitalizaciones no solamente en la
ciudad sino también en el Valle de
México
aún así la jefa de gobierno Claudia
sheinbaum asegura que no estamos ante
una tercera ola de contagios dice que es
un ligero repunte Lo cierto es que no
nada más la capital del país en otros
estados también se está viviendo este
repunte en el norte es el caso de Baja
California que tiene un récord incluso
de aumento de casos Baja California Sur
Sonora Sinaloa Nuevo León y en el sur ya
no nada más es la Península de Yucatán
sino que hay otros estados que tienen un
aumento considerable como Tabasco la
semana
cierra con un aumento de 14% de la
epidemia y se estima que podría llegar a
18%. Mario hablemos de la vacunación
importante para destacar que allí en
México Ya autorizaron la vacunación de
los adolescentes personas mayores de 12
años Únicamente con la vacuna de pfizer
en cuanto a vacunación han llegado al
país desde el 23 de diciembre pasado más
de 51 millones de dosis de las cuales se
han aplicado poco más de 42 millones se
tuvo una caída en el ritmo de vacunación
y el presidente López Obrador lo
atribuyó a la escasez del biológico sin
embargo dijo que esta situación Ya se
está revirtiendo Incluso se anunció que
se abrirán más macrocentros de
vacunación en distintos puntos del país
para acelerar y recobrar el ritmo que se
tenía antes de las elecciones a la par
la autoridad regulatoria la cofepris
anunció que autorizó el uso de una
vacuna de pfizer para menores a partir
de 12 años de edad es la primera vacuna
para este segmento de la población que
se autoriza y
México envió ya 400.000 dosis de vacuna
a Centroamérica Guatemala El Salvador y
Honduras son vacunas astracénicas que se
están envasando aquí en el país
Mario México es uno de los pocos países
que ya regresó a las clases presenciales
qué balance hacen las autoridades
después del regreso ya a las aulas de
los alumnos
de manera oficial desde el 7 de junio
1.6 millones de alumnos de 24.000
escuelas de la mitad del país volvieron
a clases presenciales sin embargo al no
ser algo obligatorio sino ser un proceso
voluntario no todos los padres de
familia están enviando a sus hijos a la
escuela el caso particular de la Ciudad
de México al Volver al semáforo amarillo
Pues fue la autoridad educativa Federal
aquí rige la autoridad Federal en la que
determinó que cada comunidad escolar
decidirá en libertad y por consenso la
asistencia a las aulas Lo cierto es que
se han dado algunos casos de contagio en
las aulas en escuelas que habían abierto
y que han tenido que volver a cerrar
tras estos brotes el presidente dice que
son casos aislados Pero también es
cierto que ya se avecinan el período
vacacional por lo que quedan unos
cuantos días de actividad En aquellos
centros escolares que sí están abiertos
para los alumnos
Mario Muchas gracias por este completo
reporte desde la Ciudad de México Mario
carbonel nuestro corresponsal allí en la
capital mexicana y Esta sí que es una
buena noticia sobre todo para América
Latina la vacuna abdala desarrollada en
Cuba ha mostrado tener una efectividad
del
92.28% según los datos que han arrojado
los estudios médicos podría ser
certificada el próximo mes de julio
veamos
su nombre es abdala la vacuna contra el
Kobe 19 desarrollada en suelo cubano
origen de gran orgullo nacional con ella
Cuba se une al puñado de poderosos
países que han desarrollado su propio
suero su productora afirma que la vacuna
de tres dosis ha arrojado un 92% de
efectividad en la tercera fase de
ensayos apenas 10 meses después de
iniciado los proyectos en los
laboratorios el cgb y el Instituto fila
de vacuna se alcanzan los datos de
eficacia como bien decías en un
escenario epidemiológico complejo
durante el fin de semana otro
laboratorio cubano anunció que su vacuna
llamada soberana 2 tiene una efectividad
del 62% usando dos de las tres dosis en
las próximas semanas se espera que ambas
vacunas reciban luz verde de las
autoridades cubanas si bien el país ya
ha iniciado la campaña de vacunación
temiendo el avance del virus
por eso la Por eso ahora la gente ha
bajado mucho más la cantidad de
contagios aquí en la Habana Cuba
intentará vacunar al menos el 70% de la
población para agosto el presidente
cubano ha aclamado ambas noticias como
una victoria científica y política bajo
un embargo estadounidense desde 1962
Cuba ha desarrollado una robusta
industria farmacéutica y de
biotecnología presumiendo de una larga
historia de producción de vacunas
y de Cuba nos vamos hasta Brasil varias
noticias destacadas a lo largo de la
semana en este país 500 mil fallecidos
escándalos de corrupción la Copa América
en pleno desarrollo en ese país
suramericano Valeria sacó en Río de
Janeiro nos va a dar más información más
detalles Valeria Yo quiero que
Comencemos por ese récord 500.000
personas fallecidas también un escándalo
de corrupción por la compra de una
vacuna y muchas noticias más Comencemos
por ahí
Brasil ya ha superado el medio millón de
víctimas del coronavirus y lo peor es
que los epidemiólogos temen que pueda
empezar en breve una tercera ola que
podría ser incluso más mortífera que los
anteriores los datos Por lo pronto no
son alentadores la media diaria de
muerte se sitúa desde hace días por
encima de los 2000 muertos y también ha
habido un incremento del 26% en la tasa
de
contagios lo que hace temer lo peor
sobre todo pensando en lo que se vivió
en Brasil en los primeros meses de este
año mientras la comisión de
investigación del senado que está
analizando la gestión de la pandemia por
parte del gobierno de Jair bolsonaro ha
lanzado esta semana una bomba hay una
sospecha de irregularidades en la compra
de la vacuna de la India la covaxim que
fue comprada por un precio mil veces
superiores al precio inicialmente
estimado hay varios problemas que hemos
conocido a través de esta comisión se
tardaron
330 días en cerrar el contrato con la
fazer hubo más de 100 emails que fueron
ignorados por el equipo de Jair
bolsonaro y sin embargo con la cobacín
se hizo una compra Express en menos de
100 días a través de una empresa privada
muy pequeña que ahora ha cerrado de
hecho bolsonaro hablado incluso de la
posibilidad de anular ese contrato la
sospecha de los senadores Es que este
retraso con las otras vacunas responde a
un esquema de corrupción para quedarse
con parte del dinero público destinado a
la compra de vacunas está todo siendo
investigado Y probablemente las próximas
semanas se hablarán mucho de este asunto
Valeria paso preguntarle por la variante
del Tae preocupación en muchos países de
América Latina Pero qué dicen allí en
Brasil porque allí ya han sido
reportados varios casos
la variante Delta preocupa y mucho a las
autoridades sanitarias brasileñas
sabemos que es una variante que se
originó en la India y que ya está
presente más de 90 países y por ejemplo
en San Pablo la ciudad más poblada y
también la más afectada de Brasil por la
pandemia las autoridades sanitarias
locales ya han destinado un hospital
solamente a tratar esos tipos de casos
que incluso pueden ser un poquito más
contagiosos además recientemente la
revista Lance está publicado un estudio
en el que se dice que las vacunas
funcionan contra esta variante pero su
porcentaje de efectividad es un poco más
bajo lo que puede incluso aumentar la
propagación de esta otra variante que
para los científicos puede ser la causa
de una tercera ola aquí en Brasil y
también en otros países de la región Por
lo pronto la vacunación en Brasil sigue
a trompicones de nuevo esta semana nueve
estados federados tuvieron que
interrumpir la vacunación por falta de
suministros sabemos que hasta la fecha
casi el 12% de la población es decir
unos 25 millones de personas han
recibido las dos dosis de la vacuna y
tan solo 69 millones de brasileños es
decir el 32% han recibido la primera
dosis decimos tan solo porque 69
millones parece mucho pero el país tiene
212 millones de habitantes la vacunación
global es un reto abismal y habría más
capacidad para poner más dosis diarias
si hubiese disponibilidad de vacunas en
suelo brasileño Valeria en Brasil tiene
lugar la Copa América está en desarrollo
Qué novedades hay en torno a esta torneo
no en cuanto a los resultados de los
partidos sino en torno a la relación que
hay entre la pandemia y los jugadores
Porque muchos han estado allí en las
concentraciones afectados por Kobe 19
desde la Copa América en Brasil y llega
una buena noticia parece que los
contagios por el coronavirus están
bajando según los datos de la conmebol
del 1,7 al 0,7% eso significa que las
fuertes medidas de seguridad que están
siendo observadas están dando sus
efectos recordamos que este torneo
arrancó entre muchas polémicas primero
porque ni Argentina ni Colombia
quisieron celebrar este campeonato en su
territorio debido a la pandemia después
el presidente de Brasil Jair bolsonaro
ofreció hacerla en Brasil precisamente y
hubo muchas críticas los comienzos
también fueron digamos así dolorosos
porque hubo muchos casos de contagios
especialmente en las elecciones de
Venezuela y de Bolivia pero parece que
ahora las cosas están bajo control sin
embargo lo que sí detectamos es un poco
de fresa de frialdad de los forofos
brasileños
en los expertos de fútbol dicen que hay
razones ha habido muchas copas Américas
en los últimos años Estamos en una
pandemia Es verdad que no hay una
cuarentena muy estricta pero no se puede
aglomerar en teoría además hay Eurocopa
en este momento y los brasileños también
están acompañando con mucho interés este
torneo y finalmente en la guerra del
fútbol entre la televisión globo y la
conmebol por esa razón el canal
principal de Brasil no está
retransmitiendo los partidos y eso se
refleja en las audiencias
gracias Valeria por este reporte desde
la ciudad de Río de Janeiro y brevemente
les cuento otras noticias destacadas de
la semana está fuera de nuestro
continente Pero también es importante
Israel vuelve al uso obligatorio de la
mascarilla a pesar de un exitoso plan de
vacunación esto no fue una garantía para
que los contagios volvieran a subir
debido a la presencia de la variante
Delta por lo que las autoridades
impusieron nuevamente el uso de la
mascarilla para así él recibió un primer
lote de 2 millones de dosis de la vacuna
jenseng que fueron donados por el
gobierno de Estados Unidos un segundo
lote de 942,000 unidades está previsto
que llegue a Brasil pronto y chile
extiende el cierre de fronteras el
gobierno chileno Indicó que las
fronteras van a permanecer cerradas
hasta el 14 de julio y solo podrán
realizar viajes al exterior Si tienen
una situación extraordinaria y tienen un
permiso otorgado por la comisaría
virtual que otorga todos estos
certificados
y vamos a hablar ahora del caso de
Colombia batió récords esta semana en
cuanto a personas fallecidas por Kobe 19
y a personas contagiadas con el virus a
lo largo de la semana Natalia plazas se
está con nosotros desde la redacción de
France 24 y nos dará más detalles
Natalia Gracias por acompañarnos hoy en
el programa y ya lo estábamos diciendo
Colombia súper esta semana las 100.000
víctimas mortales por Kobe 19 los
números indican que la situación no es
fácil y el repunte se mantiene ya van a
lo largo de tres meses que este país
está haciendo frente a este pico de
contagio
Santiago Colombia sigue en la espiral de
contagio en la que ha estado desde el
mes de abril y las cifras Siguen
aumentando sin parar esta semana superó
la cifra de los 100.000 fallecidos que
se suman a los más de 4 millones de
personas contagiadas y los hospitales
están desbordados esto llevaba a pensar
que el fin del Tercer pico de contagio
está lejos de terminar en particular las
muertes se han incrementado en las
últimas semanas tan solo en lo que va de
mes de junio se han sumado más de 11.808
es decir una media de 562 muertes
diarias siendo el lunes de esta semana
El peor día registrado hasta ahora en lo
que va de pandemia con un récord de 600
de 648 muertes estás alarmantes cifras
tienen lugar cuando el ministro de salud
Fernando Ruiz aseguró esta semana que es
ineludible que la variante Delta
calificada por la OMS de preocupación
llegue a Colombia porque es imposible
contener la expansión recordemos que
esta variante circula ya en 90 países y
su particularidad es su capacidad de
rápido contagio lo que podría poner a
Colombia en un escenario complejo si
esta variante se disemina por el país
Natalia creo que le voy a hacer la
pregunta del millón A qué se debe que
Colombia tenga este tercer pico tan
prolongado desde el final de la Semana
Santa en el mes de abril viene haciendo
frente a esta ola de contagios
son varios factores Santiago y dependen
de la perspectiva con la que se miren
son tres meses en los que el sistema
hospitalario y los contagios se
mantienen altos pero el viceministro de
salud de Colombia Luis Alexander son
moscoso dijo que en mayo se produjo un
hiper contagio consecuencia de las
protestas contra el gobierno que dio pie
a un repico y a un cuarto pico
prácticamente simultáneos por otro lado
están los especialistas que dicen que si
bien las manifestaciones han influido
desde semana santa ha habido una
apertura de la vida social y económica
Incluso el gobierno decretó la apertura
total a partir del 8 de junio para
impulsar la reactivación económica un
aspecto necesario dado que Colombia es
un país pobre con una economía informal
que supera el 47%, según cifras del dane
del departamento administrativo Nacional
de estadística de esta forma para los
especialistas la apertura de la vida
social sería en buena parte la
responsable de que el país esté y se
vaya a mantener en una alta meseta de
contagios que podría mostrar su peor
lado en el mes de julio una vez terminen
las vacaciones de mitad de año Natalia
con este panorama que usted nos Explica
el dada la situación como está Entonces
el gobierno tiene prácticamente dos
haces bajo la manga uno a pelar a la
cultura ciudadana que la gente se siga
cuidando y la vacunación qué dicen las
autoridades
la vacunación es el único contrapeso del
gobierno para hacer frente a la pandemia
si se mantiene la apertura social
ciertamente la vacunación se ha
agilizado y constantemente están
llegando al país lotes de vacunas
10,6 millones de personas ya tienen al
menos una dosis de una de las vacunas y
cerca de 14 millones de vacunas han sido
inoculadas en todo el territorio
nacional de este total 4,7 millones
corresponden a segundas dosis pero la
meta Sigue estando lejos con 50 millones
de habitantes Colombia necesita que unos
35,2 millones de personas es decir el
70% de la población sea inoculada para
alcanzar la inmunidad del rebaño muchos
ciudadanos han denunciado
desorganización en el proceso de
vacunación y la priorización de
pacientes esta semana el proceso tuvo un
freno en Seco porque se agotaron las
dosis de la vacuna de pfizer Esto llevó
a que muchas personas que iba recibir la
segunda dosis recibieron una
notificación de suspensión de sus citas
y no pudieran ser inoculadas a pesar de
ello el gobierno señaló que la población
vulnerable de mayores de 80 años la
vacunación ya alcanzó el 88%, mientras
que en el rango de 70 a 79 años ya llegó
al 75%. Natalia gracias por este reporte
desde la redacción de France 24 en
Bogotá y vemos un vistazo al avance de
la vacunación de nuestro continente el
número de personas que ya han recibido
al menos una dosis de alguna de las
vacunas que está disponible en el
mercado comenzamos en Argentina allí
15.13 millones de personas ya han
recibido la primera dosis en Perú 3.9
millones de personas ya se aproximan a
los 4 millones su vecino Ecuador 2.5
millones de personas ya tienen una dosis
inoculada Uruguay 2.1 millones de
personas ya también casi completa en la
totalidad de la población de 3.5
millones de habitantes Bolivia allí
cierran esta semana con 1.6 millones de
personas con una dosis inoculada
y ya lo decíamos también hubo varias
novedades en Chile allí como pocos
países de la región avanza la vacunación
para los adolescentes también han
detectado casos de la variante Delta y
algunas comunas de la región
Metropolitana de Santiago comenzarán a
salir del confinamiento vamos a ver cómo
está la situación Allí está con nosotros
Patricia Luna nuestra corresponsal
permanente en la ciudad de Santiago
Patricia como siempre un gustazo
saludarla y comienzo por preguntarle por
la variante Delta el primer caso ya fue
detectado en una ciudadana chilena que
reside en Estados Unidos qué dicen
Hola Santiago Chile se convirtió en el
cuarto país en confirmar la llegada de
la variante Delta a su territorio fue el
jueves cuando el ministro de salud
Enrique París confirmó que se trataba de
una persona chilena residente en el
extranjero en Estados Unidos y que al
parecer había llegado al país para
acudir al funeral de su padre las
autoridades señalaron que Se realizaron
tres pcr a todas las personas que
viajaban en el avión con esta pasajera y
que resultaron negativos y también las
subsecretaría de salud Pablo daza ha
insistido el viernes en que se está
trabajando en establecer los contactos
estrechos de esta persona mucho más allá
de lo que es habitual con el fin de
aislar esta variante que es mucho más
contagiosa que otras y que preocupa a
las autoridades especialmente en un
momento en Chile en que estamos viendo
un descenso sostenido en el número de
casos tras varias semanas de alza en el
número de contagios
hablemos ahora de la vacunación Patricia
allí ya comenzaron a inocular a los
adolescentes que balance hacen de esta
primera semana de jornada de vacunación
para mayores de 12 años
así es Santiago Chile partió esta semana
a partir del martes puesto que el lunes
fue feriado a vacunar a los menores de
entre 12 y 18 años 12 17 años lo hizo
partiendo con los personas que están en
El orfanato de la red Pública del Estado
el servicio nacional de menores el
sename y también vacunando a aquellas
personas entre 12 y 17 años que tuvieran
un cierto tipo de comorbilidades previas
también se avanzó en la vacunación de
las personas de 18 años esta semana y
vimos en los vacunatorios a muchos de
ellos esta población acudió de forma más
masiva que otras poblaciones en las que
ha habido problemas con los rezagos
aquellos que se encuentran entre edades
inferiores a los 50 40 y 30 años esos
sectores de esos rangos de edad las
personas no han acudido a vacunarse de
forma tan masiva bien sea porque tienen
compromisos laborales que les impide
acudir Aunque hubo un decreto por parte
del Congreso una ley para permitir que
los trabajadores obligatoriamente
concedieran el tiempo para vacunar para
que los trabajadores pudieran vacunarse
pero sí que vimos mucho más jóvenes en
los vacunatorios también se han
establecido nuevos vacunatorios en
lugares menos habituales para que
aquellas personas que tienen problemas
de accesibilidad o incluso no pueden ir
durante la semana lo hagan por ejemplo
los fines de semana en lugares
especiales todo con el fin de incentivar
esta vacunación en Chile que ya alcanza
al 80% de la población objetiva con una
sola dosis y a más del 65% de 66% de la
población objetivo con las dos dosis
Patricia y para el cierre hablamos de
los números de Caso la situación en
general del país y sobre todo de esas 24
comunas de la región metropolitana allí
hay novedades para los habitantes que
han dicho las autoridades allí
pues 24 comunas de la región
metropolitana saldrán de cuarentena Este
martes esto ante los avances que se han
registrado en el descenso en el número
de casos aunque los hospitales Todavía
siguen registrando una alta ocupación sí
que se ha visto en las últimas semanas
un descenso sostenido en todo el país y
casos que han bajado de los 8.000 9.000
que teníamos en un momento a cifras más
entre los 5.000 y los 3.000 chile en
este momento ya sobrepasa el millón y
medio de personas que se han contagiado
desde el inicio de la pandemia en el
país y también sobrepasa los 32.000
fallecidos en este momento las
autoridades incentivas a que aquellas
personas rezagadas acudan a vacunarse
puesto que es esta la clave que va a
permitir luchar contra la enfermedad por
el momento como estamos viendo por
ejemplo en el sur del país el Magallanes
una de las regiones que tiene una mayor
tasa de vacunación ya ha superado el 80%
de la población objetiva y donde se ha
visto un descenso muy importante tanto
en los ingresos hospitalarios como en el
número de contagios Patricia Muchas
gracias por este reporte desde la ciudad
de Santiago y así llegamos al final de
nuestro resumen semanales sigan con la
programación de France 24 sigan
cuidándose contra el 19 hasta pronto
[Música]